what you're looking at is a story it's a
story about numbers it's a story about
people and it's a story about how
numbers and people interact it's a story
about World of Warcraft in specific but
it's also a story about every video game
in a way a story about video games
themselves it's a story about why it's
rude to be bad at World of Warcraft
it's December 2004 massively multiplayer
online role-playing game World of
Warcraft is taking the World by storm
and Wallace The Gnome Rogue walks
barefoot through molten core Wallace a
proper Hobbit of a gnome doesn't wear
shoes and he's not in a hurry to get
anywhere his Guild thinks this is a
little embarrassing but it mostly just
makes for a story about a quirky weirdo
they met in this new video game
ultimately they enjoy having Wallace
around because he makes the game fun six
months later they're screaming at
Wallace and demanding that he equipped
some boots ultimatums are dropped
tempers are elevated and no one's having
a good time someone calls Wallace a bad
player no one disagrees
[Music]
instrumental play was first described by
literary theorist Wolfgang Iza in his
1993 essay at the fictive and the
imaginary Iza a highly influential
theorist saw players being divided
cleanly into the categories of free and
instrumental based on how the act of
play related to goals on the one hand is
play unburdened by systematized goals
and on the other hand play with goals in
ease's framework play becomes
instrumental the moment it has some
intended outcome something resembling
rules and structure however inez's work
this was largely to distinguish between
children chasing each other around a
field for no other reason than because
it felt fun in the moment and children
chasing each other in a game of football
with concrete winners and losers it's
discussion in relation to video games is
credited to sociologist T.L Taylor in
her 2006 book Play Between Worlds
instrumental play is a goal-oriented
approach that values efficiency
expertise and optimize strategies as
part of Play In instrumental play the
point of playing is not to reach the end
but to find the best way of getting
there this is for the record not a
discussion of good players as opposed to
bad players we are talking about the
ways you play the game in which being
good is considered desirable this is a
critical distinction and perhaps if
there's going to be one takeaway from
all of this it is this confrontation the
idea that being good at a game is a good
thing that the correct way of playing a
game is one in which you are good at the
game isn't some natural force of reality
but an imposed value if you've ever
gotten destroyed in a video game and
felt awful about it just ashamed of how
hard you got thumped that feeling isn't
objective or natural it is an
instrumental value that you are imposing
on yourself
it's common for instrumental play to be
framed in opposition to fun that they
are ends of a spectrum
this is understandable in no small part
because instrumental play tends towards
optimization which can often result in
deeply unfun player behaviors this gets
extended out to the extreme where play
framed around challenge or investment is
treated as irrational or somehow less
genuine than some hypothetically more
pure innocent unadulterated version of
play unconcerned with doing well it's
important in this conversation to
establish firmly that this is a false
dichotomy we are going to spend a lot of
time talking about how fun gets
optimized out of games which is why I
want to stress that they are not
antithetical Concepts rather than being
in conflict with one another they are
instead in tension there is not an
opposed relationship but there is a
complex one because if you back up and
think about it it's easy to appreciate
how someone can find a deep enjoyment in
improving at a skill or achieving goals
or discovering solutions to complex
problems
rather instrumental play play focused on
goals can be juxtaposed with free play
the form of play that is without ending
neither free or instrumental play can
exist in their purest form but Renee
glass in his book battlefields
negotiation describes play in World of
Warcraft as movement between
instrumental and free play
for every Arena match or dungeon there
is a time before and afterward when
you're waiting in town and just stand
there aimless this moment this is free
play approaching its pure form
an important consideration here is that
game design can rarely compel the player
to take action a game can attempt to
prescribe an action such as the famous
press F to pay respects but players tend
to chafe against moments like this as in
Clumsy hands they tend to come off as
naive or insincere or in the language of
the youth cringe
if you refuse to pay your respects then
that's it the game doesn't even end so
much as it just bricks a standoff
between you and a choice that doesn't
exist whether or not you close the
application if you refuse to pay your
respects you functionally stop playing
the game
World of Warcraft offers players a
tremendous amount of agency it is after
all an entire virtual world you are
indeed broadly free to not pay your
respects and the game is generally cool
with that you can shun levels talent
trees and even weapons and still play
the game for a very very long time in a
way that is still identifiably play why
shouldn't you stand facing a wall on the
far side of blood missed aisle and
contemplate the nature of the draenei
forever
Jokes Aside role playing is a genuine
example of the value of free play and
the fuzzy edges of instrumental play
role players engage with World of
Warcraft in a fundamentally different
way than how you or I might engage with
it they are often less concerned with
the explicit objectives of World of
Warcraft and instead prefer emergent
activities
by shunning the game's progression
system there's a clear Embrace of free
play here but when role players
self-direct say by holding an annual
Festival that raises tens of thousands
of dollars of Charity year after year
they are creating their own goals and
that morphs into a form of instrumental
play in this sense you cannot have free
and instrumental play in their purest
forms you might be surprised just how
much of the study of wow is concerned
with role-playing because it reflects a
fascinating alternative and socially
driven means of engaging with a game and
that Nuance that question of how you can
enable a form of play that by definition
doesn't concern itself with like the
numbers the spreadsheets the statistics
all the stuff that the game is
fundamentally made of that is awesome
blizzard can't force you to stop staring
at the wall but they can encourage and
discourage certain play practices and
very rarely abolish them in their
entirety
in battlefields of negotiation glasses
core Insight is that blizzard is not an
omnipotent God in the World of Warcraft
the developers are not the Arbiter yes
they have immense influence in a form of
final say but they are ultimately a
stakeholder who push their vision of the
game which either aligns or resists
against the player base writing on
Lineage 2 professor of informatics
constant steinkolder describes MMOs as
defined by a mangle of play the push and
pull relationship between game
developers and their players blizzard
has access to certain tools and means of
creating the legitimate World of
Warcraft experience they have control
over the servers and decide what bespoke
content gets made and implemented but
they are not the sole hand attempting to
sculpt the game MMOs are interactively
stabilized systems co-evolutionary the
emergent result of the intersection of
designers armed with their technology
and play players armed with their own
practices blizzard has code the players
have codes of practices social codes of
practice are the tenants laid down by
individuals within the game who have no
design power or automatically conferred
Authority these social codes are often
linked with perceptions of Foul Play and
the spirit of the game but they go far
beyond that and can shape what is
considered legitimate play in World of
Warcraft in leat noobs Mark Chen sees
success in World of Warcraft as
dynamically defined to be good at World
of Warcraft is defined by consensus put
another way you are good if you do
enough of the things that we
collectively decided that good players
do success is relative and socially
defined
for example Arena rating was very
inflated in season 2 of shadowlands
while a typical season tends to have a
median rating around 1600. season one
was severely deflated with a median
rating of 1426.
some behind the scenes tweaking leading
into season two resulted in a median of
roughly
1750. in the abstract both of these are
fine the actual underlying mechanics of
matchmaking are all relative the numbers
are arbitrary if you are a high-level
competitor The Experience on a
match-to-match basis is generally the
same regardless of what the median
rating is the shape of the curve Remains
the Same it's just shifted upwards the
hitch is that certain rewards like
titles achievements and armor are
hard-coded to specific ratings so the
inflation resulted in the prestige
rewards being available to more players
than usual many of whom would never have
qualified for it under different
circumstances
this led to a rather vocal belief that
these rewards were illegitimate they
didn't count despite the game layer
presenting these dragons as equivalent
there is a significant difference in
their social value for glass World of
Warcraft is composed of various
idiocultures groups of players linked
together by particular systems of
knowledge belief behaviors and Customs
Big Boy Raiders and role players have
totally different ways of engaging with
the world there is no single objective
way to approach wow these idiocultures
exist in layers you've got wow players
categorically PVP versus PVE
Battlegrounds versus Arenas keystones
versus raids guilds individual guilds
and of course cliques within those
guilds and players can move seamlessly
between all of these different modes all
of these different idio cultures these
different idiocultures May subscribe to
different social practices and it is the
interaction between these groups in the
constant negotiation on proper codes of
practice the glass argues shapes World
of Warcraft it is the interaction
between different groups of people that
set the boundaries and fundamental
meaning of play instrumental play has
entrenched itself as the dominant mode
of Engagement with World of Warcraft
through social codes of practice players
are subject to expectations that they
may be completely unaware of it is taken
as value neutral and objectively true
that expertise and success are the
natural objectives of play and thus the
default mode of play that players owe to
those around them in other words it's
Bad Manners to be bad at Warcraft
we're going to take a moment to talk
about the grade Vault if you play World
of Warcraft then you probably already
know how it functions and if you don't
then all you need to know is this at the
end of every week you get to pick one
reward from a grid that fills up as you
do specific group activities options are
dictated by difficulty and volume do
more stuff get more picks do higher
difficulty stuff get stronger picks in
case study a during the shadowlands
season 3 race to world first in the US
second Guild of bdg our players were
required to fill all nine slots to their
maximum potency on multiple mirror Mains
since there is an element of luck to
gearing up the top players will prepare
multiple copies of the same class in
order to have a few pools at the slot
machine and maximize the chances of a
favorable outcome for this particular
raid tier our moon can player prepared
three separate Druids our death knight
Raider prepared four death Knights each
of these characters had the same odds of
being the main character based hugely on
the outcome of their vault Rewards
these are players who are paid in
dollars for their time as part of a
pseudo-professional Esports event
achieving the absolute Optimum
performance in a raid environment is
part of their literal job description
this expectation was only maintained
until the progression period was over at
which point no one cared jobs done do
what you want a case study B Venture on
barthelers U.S rank 180th they are a two
night a week Guild that have some very
different ideas on the Vault if you'll
allow us this one Indulgence let's just
take a moment to dunk on an incredibly
stupid opinion if some of this goes over
your head don't worry about it I promise
you'll pick up on the important part so
it's season 3 of shadowlands almost
three months into a four-month season
our good friend and contributor to the
show Crystal has just come back to the
game after a lengthy break so we spin up
a group and spend a few hours hanging
out and doing dungeons in terms of gear
crystal is wearing old junk and so the
rest of us have elected to bring alts
but a member of our group The Tastefully
named moist rainbow opts to bring his
main character in part to make it easy
for us but also to fill out slots in his
vault moist rainbow is doing this for a
chance at one specific item the coveted
Unbound changeling this is one of the
best trinkets in the game for heels and
casters at this point in time we end up
doing over eight keys but only about
four of them are at level 15. moist
rainbow does not do any other keys for
the week so at the end of the week this
is what his vault looks like he has
three chances at the Unbound changeling
two will be at the maximum possible
level the changeling is one of 91
possible items
huh that's uh that's good right
yeah a little bit
okay uh having just consulted with the
team just then a player getting their
best in the slot trinket is good like if
you had a one percent chance of the best
thing happening this would be that
because it's the best in slot but
Venture fell differently they came down
hard on moist for not maxing out that
final slot there was explicit shaming
snarky remarks even cowardly
announcements from leadership about
players needing to do their part for the
team
and perhaps on the face of it you're
empathetic to all that but we have been
pissed off about this incident for
almost six months so just just give us a
minute remember this was a piece of gear
generated solely for moist rainbow this
is not typical loot drama there was no
alternate home for this trinket the
issue was entirely in the missed
opportunity at a stronger version gear
in World of Warcraft is comprised of
stats that are assigned based on the
individual item's overall budget
dictated by its slot and by its level
these stats all do and mean a lot of
different things so the ultimate unit of
measurement we use to value a piece of
gear is to calculate its contribution to
the player's damage how do we do that
well easy we build a robot to play our
character perfectly while wearing both
items ideally a couple of thousand times
just for certainty and then compare the
results typically a higher item level
should translate to a better item
however trinkets are not like other
pieces of gear their item level can be
deceptive a trinket lives or dies on its
effect
so this Unbound changeling was the best
possible trinket with an item level of
272 down six item level from the maximum
if we compare simulation results from a
destruction walk at the time we can see
that the difference is barely
perceptible on the graph this particular
simulation values the overall impact at
0.6 here are some more details on that
if you're interested but we've buried
the lead on this because moist rainbow
isn't a warlock he's a goddamn healer
and healers are a whole different deal
healers don't have the same simple
tangible benefit from Gears damage deal
is received for well over a decade it
has been standard practice for guilds to
starve their Healers of gear on the
basis that they don't really need it we
don't even have any real way to even
quantify this difference for a Healer so
while this would not be at all accurate
let's be generous and assume that it
would match this 0.6 figure this was in
the context of a guild that was nine
weeks behind the progression curve
working on bosses that have been hit by
the Nerf bats several times and just for
those in the know these people these
people with six healing Mythic Lords of
dread in in early June like I don't even
have the words gear was not their
problem so a close friend of mine was
bullied and excluded from this group for
not spending a few more hours running
dungeons to load the bases for a one
percent chance at a maybe half a percent
increase in performance but that
Improvement was entirely disconnected
from the problems that the group was
actually experiencing the reason we
wanted to talk about this is that I
sincerely could not imagine a more Petty
reason to give someone a hard time in
World of Warcraft frankly it's pathetic
this was not instrumental practice this
was a social one here the social value
of the item level was wildly
disproportionate to any tangible
mathematical value the process of
completing the necessary eight keystones
was not emergent from some necessity but
a ritualistic reaffirmation of
commitment to the group the fact that
the trinket was worth something anything
was just a pretense to enforce a
practice
foreign
attempts at anthropological studies of
virtual worlds were fraught some might
look back on them as hopelessly naive
but I prefer to categorize them as bad
many of them sought to reify online
spaces to rope them off from reality and
paint them as a separate self-sustaining
World an actual destination is
disconnected from the rest of reality as
the moon or perhaps Australia incoming
of age and second life Tom bellstorff
conducted a study of user experiences in
Second Life but critically did not
involve the user's real lives or any
other websites or software in his
analysis the work Drew criticism from
Alex golub who identified this as a
dramatic oversight the virtual worlds of
MMOs are not in closed worlds my
experience with World of Warcraft is not
limited to the executable file on the
hard drive Discord twitch Twitter Google
Docs they are all places where I can
engage with World of Warcraft without
inhabiting World of Warcraft I work as a
contributor to skill Captain analysts
for bdg I produce my own YouTube content
I might at this point spend more time
doing wow outside of wow than I spend
inside of it so we have MMO Champion
Wowhead or whatever the 10 we'll be
using for this material is paratext if
you're into a certain lame type of
YouTube video Power text is a word
you'll have heard before it's one of
those words that is thrown around kind
of haphazardly
the concept of paratext was originally
conceived by French literary theorist
Gerard Jeannette Jeanette saw a book as
containing the text of the book The
primary work but also containing other
components that were necessary for the
book to be complete but that were not an
element of the primary text
you have the actual story of Warcraft
Euro 10 but then you also have the cover
the title a forward and so on things
that aren't the text but still influence
the meaning the title gives you some
ideas to what the book is going to be
about the illustration might tell you
what a certain character might look like
fishinet all that additional text
required to make the work complete was
paratext
so we can all agree that this is
fascinating stuff really interesting but
let's be real it's not a growth industry
is it like in the year of Our Lord 2022
there is not a Groundswell of interest
in a body of Academia focused solely on
books and not like not texts but
physical books
there have been attempts to apply
Jeanette's framework to the internet if
you've encountered the term power
attacks in the wild it likely wasn't
Jeanette's definition but rather the
definition attributed to Mia consalvo
consalvo is a comps Professor who
Tastefully and delicately but firmly
expanded upon Jeanette's formulation
for consolvo paratext with any text that
may alter the meanings of a text further
enhance meanings or provide challenges
to sedimented meanings so paratext are
texts that exist to influence what we
think of a separate primary text this is
reviews walkthroughs pre-release
trailers and so on the material that
surround shape support and provide
context for texts there is a legitimate
criticism to be made that this ever
broadening definition is quickly
becoming so vague as to lose all meaning
but for our purposes this is a blessing
Wowhead and Warcraft logs are paratext
for World of Warcraft developer
interviews are paratext Forum boards and
Twitter threads have been called
paratext podcasts fan art and Machinima
straddled the blurry line of being wolf
texts and paratex converting the
original text into a parrot text that
provides context and meaning to the
derivatives add-ons have been called
paratext whatever this is paratext
[Applause]
no no no no no no no no no no no
trash flash trash flash trash
holy [ __ ] those kids are literally so
garbage in most media a movie or
painting is produced and then paratext
is produced which can then act on the
dominant text a particularly incisive
review can persuade you into a given
reading of the story and themes or fan
fiction can emphasize the prominence of
romantic tension that would otherwise
appear subtle or even non-existent that
kind of thing
maybe if a movie gets a sequel the
filmmakers will respond to what people
liked or disliked and thus the paratext
has influence over subsequent texts it
is common for paratext to alter the way
that people talk about something but for
the most part that's where it stops it
is very rare for paratex to go beyond
that and actually alter a text World of
Warcraft like many online games has a
bit of a different relationship World of
Warcraft is constantly being updated and
altered there is no static final product
that can sit on shelves and be dusted
off by critics decades later and since
wow is constantly being updated so is a
lot of the talk about wow the paratext
is in a constant state of churn in
lockstep with the game at a basic level
paratext is a form of feedback for the
Developers YouTube videos critical of
certain changes bad reviews of an
expansion launch in major Outlets
explosive Forum threads or viral tweets
the developers and writers are in an
inevitable dialogue with these parateks
as subsequent updates to the game will
inevitably be read as either integration
or rejection of the vision presented by
those Outlets
but beyond that paratext interacts with
social practices paratext emerge from
create and disseminate social practices
and what then tends to be prescribed are
ideals of instrumental play
when a new strategy or idea is discussed
people make guides or posts discussing
it and push it out into the world that
then influences how the game is played
and what practices are considered
correct and legitimate the expression of
this can be surprisingly pervasive in
really unexpected places such as which
of two perfectly symmetrical hallways is
the correct path to take there is a
shocking amount of social friction that
can be generated by looking at two
identical choices and picking the one
other players weren't expecting in the
Sepulcher of the first ones these two
paths at the entrance are the same
they're literally identical there is
absolutely nothing to distinguish going
left from going right but for whatever
arbitrary reason looking for raid groups
have established an entirely unspoken
assumption a rut-like convention that
you go to the right if you get dropped
into a randomly assembled LFR group and
you lead the group down the left path
people will yell at you these are the
foundation of all the small rituals
players engage in as they wordlessly
navigate a dungeon for the 50th time
these are the rituals that allow players
to just know what their expected role is
why they are the one expected to stand
somewhere or do something without anyone
saying anything many of these silent
ruts are just that ruts of habit with no
consequence but the reactions get even
more intense if there are consequences
even trivial ones that can be
mathematically Quantified in some way or
another as less efficient practice
in the playful dungeon the first boss
the delightfully named glob gorg will
summon sets of slime creatures that will
make their way toward him if any reach
glob gorg he'll be healed for a portion
of his health low difficulty or
uncoordinated groups usually just turn
and kill the slimes but at the highest
difficulties the standard practice is to
focus damage on the boss and prevent the
larger slumps from reaching the boss
with crowd control if executed correctly
this positioning and strategy
trivializes the fight it's not difficult
but the risk is enormous any breakdown
in the management of the slimes can
immediately brick an entire dungeon run
upon first discovering the strategy on a
twitch stream we became immediate
evangelists for the globguard Gambit we
essentially became agents of the
strategy and went on to spread its
influence even further
to quote Christine ask Theory crafting
paratext to both spread and stabilize
Theory crafted expertise co-producing a
more performance-oriented playstyle put
another way when players Theory craft
when they come up with strategies when
they run math through spreadsheets
decide which option is numerically
Superior and these strategies
proliferate through the player base they
don't merely spread the specific
strategies but also legitimize and
Elevate the active Theory crafting
itself and push all players indirectly
towards a playstyle where optimization
is the correct mode of play World of
Warcraft is so interesting because it
has lived through multiple generations
of the internet because the game is so
influenced by power attacks to changes
in our capacity for power text manifest
as changes in the game itself as the
internet changes how we communicate the
way we talk about wow also changes and
that fact changes well in the game's
early life thoughtbot and later our head
were famously major resources but they
were only as good as information that
users fed into them and it took a long
time for the sites to build up a
repository of information
and that didn't guarantee accurate
information just the existence of
information however as Mark Chen points
out that didn't stop these sites from
being expert practice
actually the complete opposite happened
rather than being seen as cheating using
Wowhead was a thing that the best
players did and in 2006 it relied on
Word of Mouth you had to be told about
thoughtbot to learn about it in her book
cheating consalvo points out how common
it was for strategy guides or sites like
game facts to be perceived as cheating
as illegitimate practices so it's
interesting how wow would invert that
Dynamic at a similar period of time and
as ask points out that's
weird when World of Warcraft released
streaming video was in its earliest
stages and it has persisted from that
into the rise of HD videos on YouTube
through to 1440p live streams on Twitch
like this is actually worth stressing
because it plays into the way that
information spread information asymmetry
has changed over the course of the game
if you were watching a strategy video in
2007 it looked like this
[Music]
but today in the Sci-Fi future of the
2020s now when the fight starts you're
going to want to spread out and take
positions somewhat similar to this now
the reason you're going to want to be
spread out like this is because arcmod
has an ability called airburst now this
does 1500 nature damage in a 15-yard AOE
around his Target in his 2013 thesis
play to win Benjamin Egleston predicted
the rise of twitch streams as a primary
source of knowledge for World of
Warcraft the printed strategy guides
that consalvo wrote about already feel
like a distant memory in 2022 it's
common for players to seek out primary
sources of knowledge in the form of
twitch streamers or relevant Discord
servers
someone looking how to play a blood
death knight in keystones has access to
live streams from dozens of excellent
blood dks potentially hundreds of hours
of vods to comb through taken in its
totality the effect of all this material
can be somewhat Insidious when
discussing strategy guides consalvo
observed that these guides taught young
players that exploration persistence and
strategizing were essential to succeed
in their given game essentially the
strategy guides taught its readers what
it meant to be an ideal gamer when Joyce
makes one of his dorky PVP guides and
pushes it out onto the internet to
Wither on the vine it implicitly
communicates that instrumental values
are desirable traits the video
inadvertently reinforces the idea that
watching PVP guides is a good thing to
be doing each video represents a brick
in an echo chamber that carries a subtle
yet deafening resonance the value
ascribed to these video turns the game's
best players into the game's biggest
celebrities this accelerates the process
as their expert practices gain
increasingly rapid adoption Christine
asked first observed this phenomenon
over a decade ago imagine having this
ringing in your ears for so long what
would that do to a person
this robot is a product of power text
it's an understatement to say that
simulations have become entrenched in
World of Warcraft they are a core pillar
of the game and are often the foundation
in which other pillars rest best install
list gameplay Gods even boss strategies
themselves are built off principles that
arise from simulations and the values
they carry when referring to the combat
logging slight Warcraft logs Eggleston
said such applications are now used
casually reinforcing competition at all
levels of play
through the production of power texts
competitive players are not only
creating emergent tools for cultivating
tactics but also repositioning the
skilled player as an influential force
in game Design This State of Affairs has
become so normalized as to be seen as
value neutral in the case of wow because
of the pace at which paratext is
incorporated into the game either
explicitly as feedback or implicitly as
a dialect of design the barrier between
wow and its paratex has become so thin
as to be non-existent and nowhere is as
more apparent than the subject of
add-ons
foreign
s are of course software that can be run
inside of another piece of software
add-ons were a major pillar of PC gaming
in the late 90s and early 2000s and they
remain extremely relevant through to
today many famous titles began their
life as mods many titles are socially
considered unplayable without modding
some Legacy titles are literally
unplayable without them especially as
hardware and operating systems leave
them behind and mods are a wonderful
tool for budding game devs to learn the
craft by poking around and fiddling with
a completed project mods are still
around but mod support is far less
pervasive than it was 20 years ago today
if a game has mod support it tends to be
a hugely influential aspect of the game
titles like Minecraft oxygen not
included City skylines and indeed World
of Warcraft don't see mod support as an
extra little feature but a core element
of their game's identity so while mods
haven't gone away a their scope is far
more limited
in 2022 the biggest titles are online
competitive multiplayer games driven by
live service monetization titles like
Counter-Strike or League of Legends
Place huge emphasis on their competitive
and Esports elements these are games
where the Integrity of the competition
is critical support for add-ons
represent an unstable element that few
game developers get involved with in
fact most developers of esport adjacent
titles have an extremely harsh view on
any third-party software that interacts
with the competitive element of their
game there are a few exceptions Team
Fortress 2 gives the player the ability
to alter the game's HUD the power the
user is given to change the UI is pretty
dramatic however they cannot add new UI
elements only alter the presentation of
Base elements the closest comparison I
was able to find to a wow UI mod was
like simple radar for Counter-Strike
this is a major Point of Departure for
World of Warcraft wow wants to be
counted amongst your League of Legends
and valorence and wow wow laid a lot of
groundwork for the modern live service
model wow wasn't built to be like those
games it was built to be like EverQuest
and Dark Age of Camelot both games from
the early 2000s with Mod support mods in
that era were significantly less potent
and the competitive instrumental play of
2022 didn't
really exist in EverQuest in 2003
there is an old Alakazam tutorial on
modding in EQ from February 2003 and it
lists the following hypothetical uses of
mods
mods can introduce new information or
functions into the EQ interface make
things easier to use or make the playing
screen more pleasing to the eye they can
turn your cursor into a Nature's Walker
Scimitar put a dragon in your Spellbook
and put every important Zone location or
great skill recipe only a mouse click
away while you're in game
these are not what we would today
consider gameplay altering mods they are
aesthetic and ergonomic changes these
are precisely the kind of mods that
developers at the time would anticipate
users creating and the appeal of these
mods are pretty clear users are
empowered to sculpt the game to their
own liking and that remarkable feature
is almost entirely outsourced mods offer
huge value to companies who are the
ultimate beneficiaries of the work of
passionate Volunteers in 2003 the
developers working on World of Warcraft
were not making a competitive title they
were making an Elder Scrolls Ultima
EverQuest type thing of course a few
people would inevitably min max the
systems like any other Dungeons and
Dragons descended but the decision to
support mods wouldn't be one with
Decades of consequences
probably
World of Warcraft in a lot of ways is a
victim of its own success its extensive
mod support is a relic of a bygone era
mods today are more powerful than the
founders could have imagined we can
argue whether an opposite should have
locked down their API more during
development but ultimately that frames
the debate as blizzard needing to save
us from ourselves the decision to give
mod developers Freedom though perhaps
naive was rooted in player and consumer
empowerment as mod support so often is
it's what modders created and now
eagerness to embrace them and that put
us in this position so while this may
seem redundant we want to take a second
to draw a distinction between add-ons
and well add-ons
on the one hand we have mods like one
bag Aurora and my role play mods that
improve the user experience or offer
some new feature without influencing
combat I would rope most of the
dragonflight UI customization options
into this category on the other hand you
have big wigs and Gladius whose whole
purpose is to improve player performance
in combat these are mods whose creation
and use is predicated on instrumental
and expert practices which is to say
these mods exist to provide information
that allows you to improve your
performance since these mods are used
explicitly in pursuit of an advantage a
conversation about cheating and
legitimacy naturally follows this is not
a binary but rather a spectrum based on
how much cognitive load of the mod is
carrying the seminal Authority on this
incredibly Niche concept is Mark Chan's
2011 dissertation Elite news Chen wrote
extensively about add-ons and their
influence on raid practices as early as
2006 but his insights have only grown
more relevant over time as the influence
of add-ons has grown in lead noobs Mark
Chan is concerned with how raid groups
become successful and the complex social
and Technical Systems that emerge in a
coordinated raid environment Chen sought
to demonstrate how add-ons could become
essential to a raid to begin Chen
develops on Edwin Hutchins concept of
distributed cognition for Hutch and many
cognitive tasks can be conceptualized as
activities that can be offloaded onto
material resources if I take notes on a
sheet of paper if I jot down the
passcode to a door or the location of a
hidden treasure I am offloading the
cognitive tasks of memory onto the pen
and paper the pen and paper are assuming
certain responsibilities they are not
passive things but are actively
performing a duty of carrying a
cognitive load on my behalf Chen takes
this concept to his logical extreme and
asks whether it even matters whether an
actor in a given system is human or
non-human this concept is called object
oriented ontology where everything
exists equally tools are treated as
though they have agency my brain and a
pen and paper are equally capable of
accomplishing the task of remembering my
doctor's appointment
there are certainly critiques that can
be made of this framework in the context
of note-taking it could be argued that
the paper merely enhances my memory
rather than assuming responsibility but
as you will see certain mods are so
potent at taking on responsibility that
agency is probably the best way to
describe it so it's the framework that
we're going to use here this leads Chen
to a lengthy discussion of actor Network
Theory AMT posits that the roles and
responsibilities within a network of
activities such as an organization or a
raid group are distributed across
multiple actors an object-oriented
ontology tells us that those actors need
not be human
and since a raid group is nothing more
than a network of actors Chen argues
that add-ons can become essential agents
in a raid environment
so the atoms we are most concerned with
are the ones that take on some cognitive
load that would otherwise be placed on
players individually or collectively
from this we can place mods on a kind of
abstract spectrum of just how much
cognitive load they carry a lot of mods
we just don't care about such as those
cosmetic or ergonomic mods because they
carry no meaningful cognitive load in
combat on the other end of the spectrum
we have Gladius diminish or omnibar and
they carry a very high amount of
cognitive load because they desperately
want to contribute to combat the
smallest example of a useful mod we can
think of our minimum unit of cognitive
load would be the Crosshair it's not
uncommon to see top end Raiders play
with the weak core that marks the center
of their screen representing where their
character is your character cannot
typically leave the center of your
screen so strictly speaking the
Crosshair is entirely redundant
information it is an actor whose role is
to answer a question that whose answer
never changes where is my character it's
in the middle of the screen where it
always is and yet if we show you footage
of a modern raid you can see how the
Crosshair can decide for the visual
noise where is my character is a simple
question to answer but having that
certainty having to not take the extra
Split Second to find your dude in the
chaos that is valuable and that task can
be offloaded to two brightly colored
lines in recent years competitive rape
guilds have made a big deal out of the
21st Raider an additional player outside
of the raid that coordinates players as
the raid's leader via live streams beam
series
and this beam is going left
dear God give us a good beam
traditionally that role was performed by
a player within the raid but the demands
of the role have grown to the point
where a player within the raid is not
expected to carry that amount of
cognitive load the cognitive load of
managing the raid has been outsourced to
an additional actor who is not on the
raid frames however that idea is not
remotely new T.L Taylor riding in 2009
on the subject of raiding in molten core
framed a predecessor dbm as a kind of
autonomous agent the 41st member of the
raid it's quite common for raid mods
like dbm or bigwigs to assign plays to
certain locations or to perform certain
duties on the Mythic Jailer encounter
six players are marked as the bomb
they're about to explode to keep their
friends alive they each need to jump in
their own unique hole to minimize the
amount of coordination or communication
required that players offload the
problem onto a mod and add-on assigns
each player their own hole and your duty
as a Raider is to do what you are told
by the time this goes live progression
for Vault of the incarnates will begin
in less than a fortnight a huge point of
discussion for us has been how to best
utilize mods to assume as much
responsibility as possible just how much
of our Right leader could be replaced
with Ms Susan in lead noobs Chen
discusses at Great length how the
creation of threat meters affected his
Guild we take it for granted today but
in early wow the threat system was a
black box the lack of knowledge around
threat meant that players couldn't
necessarily optimize their damage
because if they did too much damage they
would simply pull aggro and die and you
can put a number to what too much damage
even was Chen describes in detail his
Guild's theories on how threat
functioned I won't get into those
details but it was a vision of threat
that had Rogues afraid to ever press
eviscerate a core ability that famously
was kind of important it was worth a
press a this trade has static damage
early theories on threat were similar to
enixia's famous deep breath it was
shrouded in half truths vague
uncertainties and a healthy dose of
superstition threat in 2004 was what we
today call A vibe you felt it out a
scenario like this where DPS are
deliberately holding back their damage
due to concerns about threat it
significantly increased the difficulty
of bosses ultimately players dug in and
surfaced all the information about how
threat actually functioned the
Superstition was replaced with absolute
knowledge a mechanic that was previously
invisible but still present was made
visible in order to be made useful the
process of threat was now a process of
real-time data analysis if the Rogue saw
that they had a decent buffer on threat
they could press eviscerate where they
would have once hesitated as tools the
damage meter naturally preceded the
threat meter but in the early days the
value of damage meters wasn't
appreciated Chen observed that his Guild
members initially struggled to see the
purpose or value in these tools he
invoked the metaphor of trying to
describe a bicycle to a fish
but once they were adopted they quickly
became essential to Chen's Guild and the
threat meter naturally elevates the
damage meter because ultimately the
value of threat management is measured
in damage per second the creation of the
threat meter created the conditions that
allowed players to optimize their damage
output and thus legitimize the damage
meter as a meaningful signifier of
contribution the reason why we
articulate the value of gear in terms of
damage per second is because DPS is the
base unit that we use to measure value
to a raid what was once the central
pillar of the DPS experience the
vibe-based management of threat was
completely changed almost overnight in
the years it followed threat became a
rudderless system ignored by players
unless they chafed against it over the
years blizzard has had a few cracks at
making it relevant again but as you'll
recall the creators can't force it in
modern context it is easy to view this
as a positive thing thread threat sucked
as a mechanic and the game is better off
without it sitting on top of everything
that may be true but because nothing
with wow is simple there is more to it
than that Chen describes a couple of
different players from the early days
each with various quirks but for
narrative Simplicity we're going to
merge them into the archetype of Wallace
a character who walks between encounters
and doesn't wear shoes two real
behaviors that Chen witnessed like there
is one of my guild mates not guildmates
raid mates so he was in a different
Guild he played this character who
refused to wear boots
or Footwear like every piece of clothing
or item you get can add to your stats
right so to not wear boots is uh a
handicap
um but like we didn't care because he
was role-playing and he was having fun
stuff and so like he never ever wore
Footwear and that there's another person
who never ran which is the total pain in
the ass because like you have to wait
for this person to take forever to get
to wherever you're going but like he
never ever ran the game which is
ridiculous the experience of the
wallaces of the world was to rapidly see
the attitude of the world shift around
them from light roasting over silly
character decisions to active hostility
threat meters changed what rating meant
to RP walk everywhere wasn't a cute
character trait it was leaving the job
of trash clearing to everyone else
Wallace's lesser contribution could be
portrayed with the objectivity of
mathematics
this is how social practices change and
how mods can drive that change threat
meters and damage meters created a new
framework for which wow could be viewed
by players and as an individual you
could either accept that change or leave
Wallace not wearing shoes shifted from
being a self-imposed limitation with
very nebulous consequences to being a
very precisely quantifiable measure of
exactly just how much Wallace was
failing to play correctly
and in defining what it meant to
correctly play World of Warcraft we
narrowed down those legitimate means of
inhabiting Azeroth in doing so the
infinite World that so enthralled those
anthropologists grew just that little
bit smaller
[Music]
a typical single player game may be
built with instrumental play in mind it
may even distinctly cater to it but Peak
instrumental practices can often be
quarantined from mainstream view think
speed running
I love Dark Souls 3 but have never
seriously looked at speedrunning it in
comparison to regular play the speed
runs look incoherent the two are
disconnected to the point they're
functionally different games a rich
speedrunning scene can exist without it
influencing my experience of the game
World of Warcraft in contrast has a very
different relationship with instrumental
practices you can't really Escape them
even if you try even the social elements
of the game things seemingly free of
numbers become vessels for the
propagation of numbers
wow is a big game and it's extremely
complex and is composed of nearly two
decades of sediment long strings of
stuff positioned with little baked in
explanation for what it's for why it's
there or even if you should bother when
new content is introduced no one goes
back to the old stuff to drop signs
saying hey this place is kind of done
you sure you want to be here there's a
lot of reasons for that namely it
wouldn't even necessarily make the game
better but it's a thing and as a result
it creates a lot of cul-de-sacs if you
stumble into the molten front in 2022
it's kind of left to you to figure it
out the game's not going to tell you
that this content stopped being relevant
November 29 2011.
so given the existence of these
cul-de-sacs what is always the first
piece of advice given to new players
join a guild find people who will help
answer questions and offer guidance
people who are up to date on the game
who can collectively remember what
things are and point you at what you can
or should be doing who can tell you that
the molten front is not only a
cul-de-sac but also kind of lame and
there's not a lot of reason to be there
whether it be that kind of spontaneous
organic help or these systematized
information from elitist jerks forums
guilds are repositories of knowledge
Christine asked describes gills as
communities of practice as institutions
that store information they are
communities defined in part by what they
do and why they do it from the very
start players are primed to engage with
Wow as a process of adopting certain
practices
World of Warcraft is a game with a large
degree of interdependence and
interdependence is always a tricky mix
of Reliance and imposition in order for
you to accomplish your goals you may
require me to perform a certain task to
a certain level of proficiency and if I
can't do that well
odds are no one's going to be happy with
what happens next
Wow's raiding environment pushes this to
its Most Extreme as you'll recall Chen
describes a raid as a network of actors
like a musical band sports team or
school project as a scheduled regular
social obligation it's fair to say that
some degree of success is required to
keep players motivated to attend no one
wants to feel stuck or left behind as
discussed earlier it can be said that
success in wow is socially defined what
it means to be stuck depends on where
everyone else is the raid groups that
perform the most effectively tend to do
so by treating rating essentially like
work their work defines what success
looks like in the game and in turn their
practices become the expert practices as
anyone who doesn't want to feel stuck
adopts their strategies their group
compositions their add-ons and their
organization because there might be a
bunch of different strategies that do
work but we know theirs does work and if
it works it must work for a reason
for instance limit achieved the world
first kill of n'zoth by using an
external raid leader The Raid group was
managed and coordinated by someone who
is not among the 20 players inside the
instance this was not unheard of but it
was not a common practice until limit
success three years later it's a
ubiquitous tactic in the world first
race and our friends over at Adventure
the trinket guys they love the external
raid leader from twitch streams to full
strategy guides guilds like limit create
power attacks to document their
practices this paratext not only
contains the methodology to overcome a
specific boss fight or fix a certain
problem but you'll recall it also
normalizes itself as a legitimate
framework to apply to raiding this is a
byproduct of emergent play The Game's
best players have gotten very good at
finding unintended solutions to the
challenges put in front of them which
means that what they end up doing can
often be in conflict with what the
intuitive solution would appear to be
over the course of years Theory crafting
has become so entrenched in the minds of
even casual players that it appears
value neutral the way we conceptualize a
rating counter the terminology we used
where we judge success it is all
informed from behaviors disseminated
from the top down even when we do see
Innovation emerge from relative unknowns
like restricted's awesome Mythic Jailer
strategy those strategies are still
products of instrumental practices this
goes beyond stabilization of theory
crafting as an abstract value this is
extremely tangible this level of
instrumental play creates a player base
that is better and more coordinated than
they otherwise would be blizzard can
either ignore this and create encounters
that are trivialized by add-ons and
other techniques or they can presume
that they will be used this has
gradually resulted in content that
presumes the existence of these tools
and thus pushes players further toward
adopting them we have seen this
phenomenon play out quite rapidly in the
game's competitive PVP mods that were
once prohibited from tournament play
have become permissible and their rate
of adoption has skyrocketed this had
tremendous implications on the game's
balance the players who had a culture of
minimizing add-on usage suddenly started
outperforming all expectations and
legitimize mod usage in a community that
would otherwise be very reluctant to
ever use mods the game design is sought
to offset the mods and the game now
demands an air horn whenever among bone
dust Brew the only solution to the
impact of mods is to rely more on those
same mods it's a feedback loop as the
race to world first has continued to
pursue professionalism we've seen
add-ons become a crucial element of this
process for years now the contending
guilds have had honest to God software
developers on their roster to develop
specialized software to assist in Boss
encounters weak auras is a mod that is
so powerful it's not even accurate to
call it a mod it is one part software
development language one part mod
distribution platform it would be easier
to list the things that we callers
cannot do it could be used to
single-handedly rebuild an entire UI it
could be the only mod you ever use but
even that is underselling this thing
weak auras have become the first Port of
Call for any problem in high-end rating
applying the principles of cognitive
distribution the first question in
response to any problem is can a week or
a handle that twitch the answer is most
often yes it is increasingly common to
see mods form the spine of strategies
from these top guilds many encounters
such as Mythic fate scribe have
strategies that rely on weak 4 is to
effectively execute since deferring to
weak Horrors is the First Choice it is
extremely rare for an alternate solution
to emerge what is there to gain by
digging your heels in and not using the
assignment week or for Jailer runes
since no alternate Solutions exist these
weak or has become fundamental tools
that are adopted basically universally
the same tools designed to buy and for
professional Raiders end up as standard
practice a popular observation regarding
add-ons is the way in which they enable
or encourage surveillance among players
a mod like CT raid assist would function
if players weren't using it but its
Effectiveness was predicated on mass
adoption in the case of these auras they
require everyone in the raid to use them
in order for them to function correctly
if you join a raid and don't have the
correct pack installed all the little
elves that tell everyone where to stand
during prototype Pantheon melt down this
has led to the creation of weak auras
that ensure you have the right weak
auras Sepulcher of the first ones was
just just dominated with this [ __ ]
so to recap strategies seep from the top
down the strategies that the best guilds
use inform the techniques that will see
Mass adoption smart practice for these
guilds is to offload responsibilities
onto add-ons wherever possible which
results in a critical mass of strategies
that build themselves around these tools
since there is rarely incentive to
develop an alternative practice tactics
grounded in these mods see near total
adoption these tools rely on players
running the software individually so
players have next to no say in whether
they install this software and because
this practice is so widely adopted
blizzard quite rightly develops fights
presuming these tools will exist further
entrenching them is mandatory and
incentivizing guilds to run even more
tools to surveil raid members and
enforce compliance
and this is how a guild like mine ends
up mirroring the practices of
professionals we aren't pursuing high
ranks or looking to flatter our egos we
just want to enjoy ourselves we just
want a sense of forward momentum from
week to week but in Shadow lands we
found ourselves press people to do
things they wouldn't otherwise do
whether that's run Keys install mods
switch specs or Hell switch classes it
parallels the experience of Christine
ask who writes that her 2009 Guild the
gummy wolves sought to temper their
instrumental practices they wanted to do
well on their own terms without just
doing what elitist jerks did they mocked
the no lifers who took the game too
seriously but yet were continually lured
towards adopting the ideas and practices
and strategies offered up by elitist
jerks because
well they work
because that's the thing about these
practices they aren't arbitrary they
exist because they solve these problems
and if adopting some of these techniques
is what gets your raid group from
stalling out to comfortably succeeding
that's a trade-off that some would be
happy to take but for those players who
were left behind clearly the problem is
the game itself the co-evolution of wow
hit a dead end if you catch my drift
this arms race between the devs and the
players it's gotten out of hand what we
need to do what we need to do is hit the
reset button abandon all this nonsense
and return to a simpler time surely
surely that will fix this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
when I first covered wow classic I
painted a picture of a game whose
primary appeal was tourism a chance to
revisit a compelling game but ultimately
one without lasting appeal to a broad
player base I've received the odd
request for a follow-up video every so
often and now seems like a good times
any to indulge in the recent marketing
for Wow classic blizzard has leaned in
hard on appealing to The Nostalgia of a
mainstream audience the advertisements
are aimed first and foremost at drawing
back players who fell out of love with
the game
foreign
[Music]
however this is not how a hardcore
audience conceives of classic
is a return to when the game was more
pure for example a big complaint from
the classic web heroists are the
difficulty modes that wow introduced to
dungeon and raid content uh in the first
year of the Obama Administration
raids should be Meritus killing all
bosses in a raid should be an
achievement and players should be sorted
from one another not everyone should be
able to finish the race as an example
let's use battle desire law for 2019 the
same year classic where released this is
widely regarded as an excellent raid and
may be among the best of the modern era
here we can see the distribution of
progression for the hardest difficulty
this is where every Guild who killed the
boss finished up for instance dance
Guild killed the first two bosses on
methx so they're somewhere in this
column
as you can see the largest portion of
guilds Never Killed the second boss
twice as many as actually cleared it the
data tells us a story of The Raid you
can see just how tough the fourth boss
was relative to the first three by how
many guilds never made it past it the
distribution drops hard after the first
three bosses this distribution resembles
an ideal raid sure Dan and his two decad
old friend group they can see some
bosses they can do some stuff but at a
certain point it's time for the men to
take over
this graph isn't perfect of kung and
type would probably tell you that too
many people are clearing the raid but it
could be worse compare this to the
normal mode distribution for the same
rate normal mode represents everything
that the classic purists hate about the
modern game it's a version of The Raid
intended for any group to be able to
finish with the bare minimum of
organization we can see from the data
that the vast majority of guilds who
entered normal mode finished it this
number is pathetic it fails to
distribute players at all no matter your
skill level you can expect to clear
normal mode a distribution like this in
the context of instrumental play is
terrifying what does an objective-driven
playstyle look like when the explicit
objectives of the game can't provide an
appropriate goal sure some portions of
Stack are well served by the trade but
some unknown number would be disengaged
by this because it's just too easy what
would the game turn into for those
players if they didn't have difficulty
appropriate content a distribution like
this is deeply unhealthy for the game
and it's the reason why early Wow's
raids were so difficult
I mean that's that's molten coal man
it's the First Rate they ever made of
course it's going to be easy
uh
Dan Dagen
a lot of ink has been spilled on why
classic hasn't delivered on the
difficulty promised by those early
evangelists we won't relitigate that in
too much detail here but in short
players are better their intranet is
better and for practical reasons the
game runs on the final build of the
expansion so player characters end up
being stronger than they ought to be but
the big one is the presence of paratext
it's not just that the content is 12
years old and everything has been solved
it's that the solution has been widely
disseminated and widely adopted
like here's a taste of a three hour
lecture on changes to Shaman going from
vanilla to the burning Crusade please I
insist the testings of spell
coefficients and weapon in views I
present here we're done using a 2.4.3
TBC repack which is not an official
Blizzard product despite this almost all
spell coefficients and weaponin B
results that I've gathered corroborates
what has been actually tested by
multiple TBC era Theory Crafters however
until an official pre-patch beta and or
live TBC game has been released I cannot
be 100 sure the spell coefficients and
weapon and B results are completely
correct yeah we were always going to
demolish classic it was always going to
go this way that's not to say that
sunwell or old war raid is an
unenjoyable experience for modern
players familiar with the game it's just
that it's not strictly a challenging one
the issue then the classic faces is that
the vast majority of players are
exhausting the content at an absurd pace
most within the first week or two these
are people who love the game dearly and
are magnitudes better than the creators
could have imagined what are they
supposed to do to fill the time well the
same thing as anyone else who has a deep
love of a single game they started speed
running
speed running has been an element of wow
for basically the game's entire life but
before classic wow was released private
servers took it to a whole other level
these servers would spin up and shut
down so rapidly that players develop
techniques for Speed running the entire
game those players and their imitators
applied their techniques to Classic wow
at launch molten core was cleared in
just six days down from 154 days back in
2005. this was a big story in the
classic circles but it didn't really
affect the tourists in any meaningful
way at launch over the life of classic
more and more players found themselves
adopting more and more of these speedrun
techniques maybe it was an organic
process people just looking to make
their raids easier and find a way to
make them more engaging but I would
suggest that instrumental play compels
players to try and organize themselves
by hierarchy remember the elitist
players who want to gatekeep content
they're in here somewhere so they are
naturally going to elevate means of
separating themselves from the pack so
Speed Run practices become expert
practices and one well over the course
of years that cooks your brain classic
got to have been our Salvation from all
this after all the content doesn't
demand the kind of optimization we've
been discussing not by a long shot and
yet it's gone the other way Wrath of the
Lich King Classic has become a nightmare
of instrumental practices yes it's not
difficult but the difficulty isn't the
appeal instead it's about going through
this process perfectly to be good at
Classic is to learn and adopt the right
practices to play the right class of the
right race with the best professions to
level the quickest gets served first get
that shadow mourn that you never got
back in the day in some cases it seems
really weird it's like reliving High
School this time you're going to pick
better electives be cooler bet on the
Cubs in 2016 and smash when you've got
the chance at the launch of classic
these practices existed but they were
largely Invisible by definition it did
not mean anything to you that some guys
were in molten core while you were in
Wailing Caverns whatever but after you
quit classic at level 47 these players
they stuck around and they establish the
practices of what it meant to play
Classic this process of writing the
curve to the greatest extent possible is
not the exception it's the rule again
look at these distributions no child is
being left behind here if you're
entering the raid you're finishing it
returning to wrath classic in late 2022
there is a palpable feeling that you've
walked into their space a walk around
dalaran showcases this every death
knight and their ghoul is decked out in
the best gear the most prestigious
vanity items every player looks like the
protagonist things that were once status
symbols are mundane the best gear is not
a symbol of exceptionalism it's a symbol
of parody having less than the best
makes you less than everyone else
because if you aren't here where else
can you be this was made Crystal Clear
during the launch of Wrath classic when
players put absurd gear requirements on
groups for utgaard keep if you wanted to
experience suitcard keep the famously
easy introductory dungeon on the first
day of Wrath a majority of groups
expected you to have the best gear
possible Choice thought it was just his
sweaty server but no YouTuber azimus
parodied this phenomenon and the
comments section is full of accounts of
similar experiences madok you are not
good geared enough for this dungeon what
is he joking like our trinket from
earlier it wasn't actually about
efficiency there is a limit on how many
times you can do a dungeon within a
given time it was not about efficiency
it was about reinforcing the end group
and excluding the out group the
instrumental practices of classic are no
longer invisible they're in your face
they're the status quo it is no doubt
possible for a casual Guild of
40-somethings to have fun on classic but
like Christina asks Guild back in 2009
these practices are endemic to Classic
there's no Ivory Tower for the best
players to escape to all of you want to
do naxxramas this week I would argue
that casual players feel more out of
place on classic because it disrupts an
otherwise seamless flow of knowledgeable
and overpowered players blowing through
trivial content this is the distance of
the marketing of classic blizzard wants
classic to be inviting to returning
players a chance to return to a humble
era of course this is [ __ ] wrath was
the expansion that gave his gear score
which if you want to talk about mods
influencing social practices there's a
doozy for you the social experience of
classic is immensely frustrating and
Incredibly [ __ ] stressful once you
Step Beyond the leveling experience
every dungeon or Raid is a ritual of
actions that have been accepted as
standard and performed without
introduction it's disorienting to have
ancient dungeons being done with private
server routes stuff you were meant to
learn seven years ago from a Russian
Hunter on war man's time 7 experience
blizz-like printer for our server there
is a tangible sense of always being
behind the curve always missing
something I was so excited for classic
TBC before I learned that a bunch of
gear from vanilla was just on the best
in slot list like the mark of the
champion was being used all the way into
sunwell it wasn't that I needed it to
kill brutalis but it was the knowledge
that I was already behind classic pushes
you into one of two archetypes either
you buy in and end up here or you reject
all of this and embrace the identity of
a tourist the hardcore players
congregate on the same small handful of
servers the Casual players find their
servers starting to die and eventually
need to either transfer to those same
super Realms or endure their degrading
server until it eventually becomes
unplayable and the players drop the game
altogether in other words it's just like
[ __ ] retail
despite the promise of a journey to a
better yesterday we ultimately recreated
the same environment as the main game
only there is no border to delineate
between the intensity of content for
example bdg are a pseudo-professional
guild our Raiders are paid in dollars to
play WoW and perform their best in the
raid content they have a lot of
expectations to meet and our analyst
team has been hard at work discussing
what needs to be done in preparation for
this upcoming event one conversation
that hasn't really come up at all is the
leveling process blizzard has had years
to separate the leveling from the
hardcore elements of the game
our Raiders need to get a certain number
of characters to max level in the first
week and some are genuinely going to
Blitz it because that's just in the
nature but for our purposes there is no
need to prescribe a method to them or
push them really hard to get it done
quickly they're allowed to take their
time react to cinematics with their
viewers explore goof off whatever many
will experience the leveling of
dragonflight entirely organically like
you would or as I will
by contrast check out this selection of
guides on speedrunning to max level in
classic there is a whole industry built
on selling new instrumental practices
the funniest thing I saw in classic with
these guys who call themselves team
Supreme so if the context here I joined
a kind of middling Guild on a middling
PVE server for classic and I really I
wanted to sort of strike that balance
between hardcore and Casual play I
wanted to do well and sort of skip the
the failure portion but not have to go
too hard and within this Guild were
these guys team Supreme and they were
set on being the first people on the
server to get to level 70 in the burning
Crusade so I I approached them out of
you know sincere curiosity and I just
asking like hey you know what's the plan
and they tell me that they want to do 60
to 70 in 20 hours
and that's a that's a complicated number
to have picked 20 hours so if you're if
you're a professional speedrunner if
you're a joker and and that that is his
name his name is Joker
um if you're Joker and you do this for a
living 20 hours is a pretty doable
number but I picked these guys because
they were were a middling I picked them
because I didn't want them to have heard
of Joker so to see
so much energy being funneled into like
these Five Guys to do this one activity
and to hear 20 hours out of them
um I knew they'd made a mistake
somewhere like to be honest like not to
be rude but to hear 20 hours from these
guys it's like okay
a mistake for me I became obsessed with
this because in a way it was a thing of
like am I the one out of touch right
have have these guys pushed this farther
than I could possibly have ever imagined
um or have they made this this crucial
mistake seeing all this work juxtaposed
with what I thought was just a ungodly
number I had to know what was going on
so I asked them like hey have you been
on the beta have you tested this
strategy to which to my astonishment
they said yes they log into beta turn in
all the prequests that process takes a
full hour and that's them one and a half
levels which is like that's a really
good outcome that is solid stuff and so
at the end of the first hour they're
doing really well looking good they then
proceed to run dungeons for the next
nine hours straight so by the tenth hour
they're at level 65. it's the halfway
mark at which point they're not gonna do
the full 20 hours straight of dry run on
the beta so they log off because it
logically follows having just done 60 or
65 in 10 hours 10 more hours of dungeon
running we'll get them to level 70.
foreign
[ __ ]
[Music]
at times like this people show you their
true colors I could have stopped them I
had multiple opportunities to stop them
but I wanted to see this train reach its
destination I was revealed to be an
[ __ ]
but then they streamed the whole thing
and when the penny finally dropped they
stuck together they were deeply
miserable but they didn't point fingers
and they didn't yell instead they pushed
through it they didn't sleep 20 hours
became 37 but they got what they wanted
they were the first group on the server
to hit max level and they even finished
two raids before anyone else they won
thank you
they had months to pick up on their
mistake what business did team Supreme
have trying to replicate the practices
of speedrunners well because the
internet told them to what else were
they gonna do
as players the push for classic was in
the name of recapturing an essence of
the game that was lost and blizzard
played their part they gave us the
executable file but It ultimately failed
because we brought the bug back with us
we brought back the paratext industry
that sells Solutions we brought back the
practices that trivialize content and
when we had nothing left to do we made a
leaderboard out of our day-to-day
experiences
shout out to Rooster juice and then 957
heroic Nexus time what a legend
this discussion has been dominated by
sociology and anthropology we have
talked to death about wow as a series of
behaviors and Trends but no one who came
to wow in its early years was drawn to
it by the promise of adopting a series
of social practices the genre of virtual
worlds are defined first and foremost by
just that the world we can see that in
how Azeroth is regarded it is considered
the main character of wow the craziest
thing about this franchise is that the
world itself is probably the most key
character or that's
crazy right it's very very cool sure we
can make fun of the many self-inserts
and overplayed characters but at the
root it is the World of Warcraft for
many players in 2005 possibly even most
players the Persistence of Azeroth and
all that came with it the day night
cycles the weather the scheduled events
the ability to walk in one direction for
two straight hours and experience not a
parade of procedurally generated noise
but hand-crafted Vistas we had
experienced nothing like it the world of
Azeroth is beautiful
The Raid experience
that's a different story
raids in World of Warcraft can be
severely taxing on Hardware especially
for weaker machines this was keenly true
in the game's early years when Hardware
was both less powerful and raid groups
involve significantly more players it
was often necessary to lower graphical
settings to improve Hardware performance
just to make the game playable or if you
were choice and 13 be completely
oblivious to that and raid it two frames
per second
incredible obviously choices performance
was hindered by his single digit frame
rate altering your graphical settings
would improve the game performance and
result in better play performance a
better experience a more playable game
this line of thinking opens the doors to
manipulating the graphical settings for
efficient play a simple example would be
something like this this Quest involves
collecting bottles that are obscured
amongst the grass you can either search
the grass carefully for the tiny little
bastard bottles or you can open up your
graphical settings pull the ground
clutter slider to one and remove almost
all grass from the environment revealing
the bottles completely unobscured expert
practice is to manipulate the world to
the greatest extent possible in the
service of instrumental play the potion
of Inky Blackness is a cosmetic item
that shifts the player's perception of
the world from day to night it has no
overt value but when used in specific
environments it increases the contrast
on certain visual effects making them
easier to see in Sepulcher of the first
ones the potion saw usage on five of the
11 bosses the potion heavily Alters the
color palette of the environment it
doesn't necessarily look bad but it's a
bit chunky and certainly not what the
environmental artists intended for the
space a long-standing practice is
involved using console commands to
increase the follow distance of the
in-game camera to its maximum extent at
its most extreme it zoomed further back
than the isometric camera of Warcraft 3.
the player character reduced to a barely
identifiable spec this God's eye view
like in an RTS allows us to take in more
of the play space in 2016 blizzard tried
to Reign the sin and drastically limit
the maximum camera distance as we have
come to expect the players took this in
stride adjusted their behavior in
response and remained above all
respectful in their dealings with their
fellow man
just kidding they freaked the [ __ ] out
it was among the biggest controversies
of its kind blizzard completely
blindsided eventually backed down and
only made a smaller adjustment they
limited the camera enough to annoy
players who become accustomed to viewing
the game like a World War II bomber
pilot but not enough to fundamentally
change the look of the game it remains a
contentious topic to this day Blizzard's
argument for a reduced camera was based
on the nature of wow as an RPG they
argued the players ought to feel
attached to their character and feel
like they are within the world the
difference between this and this
it has been observed for a long time now
that expert practice is to disable the
diegetic sound but particularly the
game's music raids rely on coordination
which is often done over voice chat
software to make sure communication is
clear players often turn the game sound
way down if not off altogether the oral
scape of the environment is removed
before the instrumental player rebuilds
it voice communication is one Element
and then the alerts of add-ons serve as
another the game already features audio
cues for critical events cues lovingly
crafted by designers trying to build a
cohesive subtle thematic experience but
if you need to make snap decisions maybe
play a safe and replace combustion with
the Wilhelm scream in the absolute top
Mythic keystones the combat is so busy
that all possible senses are used to the
fullest extent possible
man
that cacophony that's the soundtrack of
keystones that's the music of victory
what's really important to note is that
the music of Victory isn't the music of
the game itself it's almost perverse the
degree to which the soundtrack an entire
pillar of the creative product has been
functionally erased from the game for
the median player having been shut off
in 2007 and never restored all of this
is about tearing down the original
soundscape of World of Warcraft and
repurposing it as a means of success
Josh Keaton's performance as anduin Rin
is muted so you can better hear a 29
year old software engineer from Montana
coordinate the most efficient movement
between lanes of zombies
and with all this established we can
finally say the quiet part out loud
players make World of Warcraft look
[ __ ] ugly instrumental play values
Clarity but only Clarity in regard to
information it's easy for this
conversation to get caught in the
Quagmire of personal preferences but
these interfaces are not the product of
pure creative expression they are the
product of instrumental practices so
let's go straight for the jugular and
highlight Mythic archimonde as an
example of what we're talking about
Royal chaos was a pretty nuanced ability
but to be brief players needed to be
aware of these arrows the telegraphed an
upcoming attack Clarity of the
environment was incentivized you can see
that in how limit positions themselves
in this footage it provides a Clarity to
what is going on even through a kind of
busy UI there was another solution
though one that did not demand any
Clarity of the environment and it looked
like this
players used a weak or that would
attempt to represent the trajectory of
the beams as two-dimensional vectors
it's pretty accurate but not really as a
means of trivializing the mechanic it is
highly effective it's also objectively
awful to look at there's no personal
preference argument here these vectors
are entirely function the Hellfire
Citadel archimonde encounter was already
a kind of unpleasant fight visually but
players pushed it completely over the
edge Mythic archimonde is a sincerely
ugly fight to look back on because it
will forever be through this lens this
mess
Alex golub called this the process of
decomposing the world and we've made an
art form of it in context go up as using
the term decomposing as the inverse of
composing a dismantling of the world but
the imagery of decomposing of Decay that
does feel appropriate there is no
conspiracy no Central Authority no plan
and yet we are uncompromising and
unrelenting
but it's just natural
and if we could roll the credits there
that would be a great ending if only it
were that simple the relationship
between instrumental play and fun is
messy we are far from the first to
observe these issues they aren't exactly
hard to see a common solution put
forward is to heavily wind back if not
outright remove the game's add-on
support despite everything that's not a
solution we're super crazy about mods
offer unparalleled value to the consumer
there is a reason they were and remain
so beloved by PC Gamers mod support is
not solely this engine of chaos that
we've depicted it as it is a means of
empowering users for that reason the
application of mod spans far beyond what
you'd expect the tournament of Ages the
charity role-playing Festival from
earlier yeah that's built entirely off
the back of add-ons disability is an
enormous subject that is so important
that we weren't sure how best to handle
it for what it's worth Choice doesn't
like to make a big deal about it but his
eyes are cooked he's very much reliant
on add-ons to play his best and so that
will always short-circuit this type of
conversation mods offer a means of
excess possibility that are both Broad
and granular custom to every
individual's need to a degree developers
can never practically match MDT on
incredibly complex mod that allows
players to plan and share routes through
dungeons has dramatically altered the
way the dungeons are designed by
equipping players with the tools and
language to communicate complex
interesting strategies arguably this
whole process of negotiation the arms
race between players and designers has
resulted in more replayable engaging fun
content mods are ultimately an
expression of our own behaviors
instrumental play the act of attempting
to solve a game ironically can't be
solved it's not a puzzle box but an
expression of values and mods are just
one of the ways in which that manifests
for all the drama that can be rung from
golub's writing his conclusion is not a
tirade against mods or those who use
them instead golub sees this as evidence
that virtual worlds are made compelling
not by their fiction but from their
reality we're World of Warcraft is the
product of the emergent collusion of
developers and players social practices
go a huge way towards defining how we
got to this point to lay the blame at
the feet of just players as a collective
to argue that the game would be improved
if only Microsoft's Activision Blizzard
King just had the control it needed to
realize its Creative Vision I'm not
loving that World of Warcraft is an
emergent culture that is constituted by
its players its inhabitants if you want
to be romantic Modern World of Warcraft
is a mess in a way that only Humanity
could create gets full of contradiction
and hypocrisy it rewards our worst
impulses before demanding payment in
full certain anthropologists feared that
Wow's nature as a game would undermine
its value as a site for cultural study
that incentivizing behaviors would
generate inauthentic data but this feels
plenty authentic to me golub suggests
that in the face of digital spaces we
retire the concept of the real world
especially as the ideas posed in
opposition to the virtual where
experiences in one are true well
experiences in the other are false fake
or fictive that whatever happens online
it's not real this framing neglects to
Encompass the very real humans who
utilize these spaces bringing with them
all their human attributes their drama
the tangle of their lives virtual spaces
are not apart from the world but an
extension of it and to this golub
suggests a much Tamer distinction
between the virtual world and the actual
world demoting the physical to a mere
subset of reality the key feature of the
actual World which Virtual Worlds must
share with it in order to become
compelling is not it's Visual and Sonic
realism but the fact it is a forum in
which we give our lives meaning by
entangling them in projects we undertake
with others worlds become real when we
care about them not when they look
similar to our own
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]